hi and thank you for uh inviting me to
speak in BIO conference live this is
David Simer I'm going to tell you about
some of our recent work where we have
been studying uh the effects of human
papala virus in uh human
cancers uh we've taken a
multi-disciplinary approach to try to
understand the biological and genetic
impacts so um I wanted to start first by
uh thanking are uh my great team of
collaborators and colleagues uh they
include members of my laboratory uh and
Mora gillison's laboratory at Ohio State
along with uh Ted technos uh in
particular I wanted to uh acknowledge
and thank um the tremendous
bioinformatic work of K aagi and as well
um uh to thank the wonderful work
molecular work of Jing Fong Lee in the
lab as well we have collaborated ERS at
the National Cancer Institute in Thomas
Reed's laboratory and at Mass General at
Harvard University I'm sorry it's
overwritten there but from jimes Rocco's
lab and funding is indicated there
below so um what's known about human
Poma virus well they've been known to
cause human cancers for several decades
now uh these are small circular DNA
viruses humans are the only host of them
uh there are over 130 unique types of PB
and they uh infect both cutaneous and
mucosal sites there are high-risk and
low-risk types of virus so we're going
to focus on uh impacts in uh genomes of
cancer cells and so we're studying uh
highrisk HPV types the genomic structure
of HPV is shown here there are early and
late genes uh indicated the famous uh
anagen are E6 and E7 over here I will
try to Circle them for you there they
are uh as well there are Lake genes and
then there is an upstream regulatory
region which is a promoter for the
circular viral
genome uh so um E6 and E7 are a aqua
proteins and they disrupt the famous uh
tumor suppressor genes p53 and prb in
the uh in the host cells uh and they
disrupt their function leading to uh
cancer so when we started our project
what did we already know about impacts
of HPV integration in human cancers uh
frequently the virus is thought to be
episomal in head and neck cancers and in
cervical pre-cancer lesions uh
integration has been correlated in
cervical dysplasia with
severity uh integration seems to
stabilize E6 and E7 transcript stability
uh and integration is thought to disrupt
uh the viral uh Gene E2 uh however to
date there have been minimal functional
consequences known of viral integration
so that's what we wanted to study in our
in our project here so our goals were to
um uh uh characterize the viral genome
in cancer cells and as well to
understand the HPV transcrip by
conducting RNA seek and in particular we
wanted to look at um the genomic
integration events of the virus in host
genomes uh we wanted to investigate
potential interactions between the viral
uh and host genomes and Cancers and
wanted to find any potential functional
consequences of um viral
integration so in our initial project we
started with 10 uh wellestablished
cancer cell lines and additionally we
had two primary head and neck tumors
available we used the alumina genome
network uh on the high seek 2000
sequencing platform uh we conducted uh
100 base pair paired and read uh
sequencing
where the average Library fragment size
for our whole genome shotgun approach
was 300 bases and we um obtained per
genome about 100 gigabases of uh
coverage at 30X at least coverage across
the genome we used aluminous pipeline to
align originally the uh um whole genome
sequence data and then um we mapped
viral insertional Junctions using a
custom pipeline that kakagi developed
using bwa and G snap uh software uh in
addition we characterized and confirmed
integration sites using glase chain
reaction and Sanger sequencing uh and we
had to reconstruct and uh confirm uh
these complex genomic structures that
I'm about to tell you
about so um one of the first things that
we did in this study was to characterize
mutations in well-known cancer-causing
genes that have already been found found
to be uh players in human cancer
formation and the list is shown here we
found typically uh a similar number of
single nucleotide polymorphisms and
insertional delal polymorphisms in each
cancer genome and as well nine of the 12
samples that we were studying was HPV
positive uh three of them were HPB
negative and in each of those they had a
concomitant p-53 mutation so typically
one or the other mutation uh or the
viral presence was was part of each
genome in addition we saw these
mutations in other well-known
cancer-causing genes including
cdkn2a and others as shown here in this
table this was recently published in
genome research and the reference is
shown
here so uh when we looked at the uh the
viral genome in each of these uh cancers
um the type was typically the high-risk
type
hpv16 one of the primary tumors which we
call tumor a and oral cancer had HPV 18
uh and um uh they had uh typically a
range of copy numbers per genome which
we characterized using quantitative PCR
uh ranging from um one up to uh several
hundred as you can see up to over 800 uh
different uh uh copies of the viral
genome uh in each cancer cell that we
studied so when we um mapped the the
coverage of viral whole genome
sequencing to the viral reference genome
shown at the bottom of this figure we
saw a wide range of um coverage of the
virus as you can see this is using the
integrated genome viewer from the broad
Institute igb and what you can see in
these blue histograms is the depth of
coverage of the whole genome sequencing
across acoss the viral genome and what
you can see in particular here is that
um uh the E6 and E7 uh genes were
present in every single cancer cell line
or tumor that we studied by contrast
some of the uh parts of the viral genome
were completely absent from uh the viral
genome and uh now I'm going to circle
some examples of that here for the top
cell line which is
hms1 you can see that the viral genome
was not present the stretching from E1
up through about L2 of the viral genome
the red histograms indicate the viral
host break points and what you can see
is that the virus integrated into the
host genome in each of these cells
samples as well when we mapped these
insertional break points across the
viral genome what you can see is that uh
we were able to verify virtually all of
the uh insertional break points that we
identified we verified them using PC R
and um the size of these circles in this
histogram are indicating the number of
genome reads that we use to um validate
each insertional break point so this um
u refuted a a conventionally held Dogma
which is that the virus has insertional
break points that occur in particular
spots of the virus genome and instead
what we observed is that the insertional
break points were distributed all across
the viral
genome now uh when we used seek uh to
analyze the HPV transcripton in cancer
cell lines and tumors what we saw is
that every single cell line or tumor
that we studied had uh HPV E6 and E7
transcribed and these sashini plots as
they're so-called from um RNA seat data
indicate that the um uh RNA seat reads
we mapping to uh the E6 and E7 genes
again so I'm going to circle that here
and want you can see is that E6 and E7
were always present in all of these
cancer
samples um by uh contrast when we looked
at the copy numbers of the um uh the
post genome in HPV positive versus HPV
negative um cancers we saw
characteristic gains and losses of
certain chromosomal arms so this has
already been quite well known in the
field of HPV cancer formation uh but
very frequently uh chromosome 3p was
lost and chromosome 3Q the long armor of
chromosome 3 was gained in most of the
samples whether they were HPV positive
or negative and this has been confirmed
by other groups over the last many years
uh using a variety of
methods uh when we uh plotted our data
using surface plots this is looking at
one of the cell lines that we
characterize what we saw very consistent
with what I just showed you a few slides
back back uh was that the HPV genome was
partially represented so that uh in the
orange histogram here going around the
viral genome in a circle what you can
see is that the coverage of the whole
genome reads indicated that certain
parts of the viral genome were present
but other parts were absent and in
particular uh break points going into
the host genome are indicated in these
red dots here and uh the virus
integrated uh in a very characteristic
fashion as I'm about to tell you when we
look at the kot type of the whole host
genome on the right surface plot what
you can see in the red arcs is the
chromosomal translocations that we had
high confidence to support the
histograms going around the circle
indicate gains and losses of chromosome
arms uh that we identified using the
genome
sequencing so um let's zoom in and look
at the uh impact of virus insertions at
a couple of locations in a couple of our
cancer samples so again these are igb
views these are uh these graphs are
indicating uh depth of coverage of our
whole genome sequencing read and as a
comparison we plotted uh the coverage
for a control normal cell uh in yellow
in blue was the cancer cell line that's
indicated so at the top is the
well-known cervical cancer cell Sia at
the bottom is a head and neck cancer
cell called HMS 001 and once you see in
these histograms is that right around
the sites of viral integration are these
very large uh gains and losses of
coverage of the sequencing indicating
that there is focal uh amplifications of
the host genome right near the viral
insertion these histograms in red
indicate break points between the virus
and the uh the host genome I'm circling
a couple of them and you can see that
the host genome and the virus insertion
right into the host genome
immediately flanks these sites of host
uh copy number variations and
rearrangements so we saw the same kind
of pattern again and again as we looked
across the different cancers that we
studied and we uh came up with a model
to explain how these uh complex genomic
structures could
be uh arising and how they could be
explained uh this is a model that we
call looping and what we're indicating
here at the top in the shadowy bluish
area is a histogram indicating again the
depth of coverage of the whole genome
sequencing these red arcs are connecting
the host host break points that we
observed and then in Black uh we saw
deletions of host host uh genome and
then these red arrows that are indicated
in this graph indicate uh viral
insertions themselves and so what we saw
was a complex structure where uh the
virus insertions went right into the
host genome and mediated somehow this
complex host genome amplifications and
rearrangements right around the viral
insertion sites so this model we call
looping and what we uh infer is that
when the virus inserts into host genome
uh perhaps its origin of replication uh
mediates replication of DNA strands
which uh loop and transiently form these
Loop structures which then resolve into
um uh camer arrays of the uh of the
virus and the host uh genomes together
so I'll give you a couple more examples
of this uh here's another cell line a
cancer cell line again called HMS 00001
we were just talking about this HPV
happened to land into a transcription
Factor called E2 and what you can see is
right around the sites of viral
insertion were uh uh host amplification
and rearrangement and the virus was
right in the middle of follow this
action again our model for looping of
how this happened is indicated at the
bottom and if you want to have more
detail about our model certainly please
look up our uh recently published paper
in genome research it explains it in
more detail than I have time to tell you
about here today so here's the model uh
here at the top is host genome um
sequence and you can see uh segments
marked a through F at the top is your
favorite Gene that's yfg up at the top
with its exons and IND introns indicated
and in red is indicated the HPV viral
genome and again this is our model to
explain these structures that we observe
in the cancer cells of uh far after long
after the uh Act of viral integration
happened so what we're seeing is that
transiently the virus inserts and then
um some focal genomic uh replication
happens uh with rearrangements and
amplification and the end result is
concatemerized arrays of these complex
copy number variations and uh
rearrangements that seem to have the
virus uh inserted right into the middle
of them uh again uh I'll give you a
couple more examples of this so here's
several more cancers that we studied and
you can see sometimes that the
amplifications of the host genome around
the viral insertions are massive so uh
in these blue histograms at the top are
the amount of depth of coverage of the
post genome what you can see is that uh
in some cases the amplification was up
over 50 fold or even close to 100 fold
amplification locally in copy number
variants in red again are the viral
break points where the virus inserted
into the host and again we see the virus
and the host uh genomic instability go
together uh in all of these kinds of
cancers that we
studied um we also saw examples of um
host genome dels mediated by the virus
insertional process so here in yellow
again at the top is a histogram
indicating depth of coverage of a
control sample in blue is our cancer
cell line sec2 and what you can see is
that there's a big gap right here in the
middle which I'm circling right now
which was uh presumably mediated by the
viral insertional process so that uh
when the virus went in the host
rearrangements happened and this chunk
of the host genome was deleted in the
process of the viral
insertion so um we saw some examples of
cancer cells that had lots of uh
instability and complex integration
events here are some circus plots
indicating uh the viral genome on the
left and the host genome on the right in
casy cells another well established
cancer cell line and again we indicated
uh uh host break points and viral
insertional break points in these dots
on the surface plot on the left uh as
well there's all of these chromosomal
translocations as you can see with these
massive number of arcing um arcs around
the circus plot on the right are is the
host genome and you can see the carot
type of the human genome going around
the circle from one to 22 X and Y and
then as well you can see the uh uh depth
of coverage of each chromosome and again
where are the insertional break points
so we were a little concerned about our
using just the whole genome sequencing
data to um understand such complicated
events and so we turned to our colleague
and collaborator Thomas Reed at the NCI
who's well-known uh cytogeneticist and
he used U beautiful fluoresence imuno Mr
chemistry uh in Su true hybridization as
well as spectral carot typing to confirm
that the HPV insertional events
correlated with some of these
chromosomal uh translocations and uh
break points and so on and so again this
is presented in our recent genome
research paper but you can look and see
that where are the uh red dots here on
the bottom left uh which I'm circling
now those are the HPV insertional sites
and they seem to correlate at least in
many cases to uh chromosomal
rearrangement that you can see from the
sky results here in the center so very
interesting and in general the fish in
Sky confirmed very nicely what we found
with the whole genome sequencing uh
analysis so uh we also saw evidence for
uh chromosomal translocations that were
mediated by HPV insertional events this
was looking in a primary tumor again
it's presented in our genome research
paper uh this is a tumor that we call
tumor B what you can see is is that
there were viral break points on
chromosome 11 and chromosome 8 here on
the top and bottom and they are bridged
together by this kind of a looping event
where there are host genome
amplifications and deletions and
translocation Al together connecting
these two chromosomes in the tumor so
this is just more evidence for the same
phenomenon it's presented in that paper
so I'm going to go quickly over it
because time is limited uh and again uh
we found many cases where there is um uh
quite a lot of evidence for complex
structural rearrangements around HPV
insertional sites uh this is now uh
focusing on another primary tumor which
we call tumor a and we found hpv1 18 in
this tumor not hpv16 and again the same
story where you saw huge uh
amplifications and rearrangements of the
host genome indicated up here at the top
connecting parts of the genome that are
normally not con us and then uh we tried
to resolve these structures as indicated
at the bottom again uh consistent with
our looping model some of these
rearrangements happen 15 to 30 times uh
connected by viral insertion
sites um we um characterized across this
panel the extent of hyperamplification
and the extent of structural variation
that we observed and what we saw was
that in a local window around the virus
um there was a a very high frequency of
both hyper amplification as well as
structural variation correlating with
HPV insertion sites in each and every
sample with very few
exceptions um so in summary what I'm
trying to say here is that uh when we
add up all of these insertional events
in the cancer cell lines and tumors that
we studied in our first project we see
uh viral insertions that are really uh
hitting across the human genome in a
wide range of locations it seems to be
fairly random as a process of where does
the virus insert but then in any given
sample we see again and again evidence
for local insertional events that are
clustered and as well uh bridging these
uh local amplifications and
rearrangements so when we plot all of
the insertions across the human genome
from all of the tumors that we've looked
at it looks in some level like they're
clustering in hotspots but these are not
from different tumors these are all each
of these clusters is occurring in one
cancer sample and so what we're seeing
is that um uh when the virus inserts it
seems to go in and then a lot of
rearrangements happen such that the
viral copies uh increase over time right
at the site of in the locus of the uh
initial insertional events so last year
uh beautiful paper appeared in nature
from Jon gur's Lab at University of
Washington uh in nature indicating that
they had um used a range of genomic
methods to study uh the hila genome the
well-known cancer cell line hila cells
and uh they presented evidence really
supporting the same phenomenon that I'm
talking about which we call hbv looping
so you can take a look at their paper
and find really good support um with
hype resolution indicating that again
these structural rearrangements blank
and are right around uh HPV insertional
sites we turned to transcriptome
analysis using RNA seat and we prepared
a range of different libraries this was
work largely done by Jing Fong Lee in
the lab uh beautiful work where he
prepared a series of libraries to
characterize the transcriptome and all
of our cancer cells then the um
alignments were performed by kagi using
top hat or gnap software where she
aligned
each of these transcriptomes to the
human genome reference genome
hg19 together with the HPV reference
genomes and then she detected chimeric
transcripts using a software package
called
Hydra uh and in this analysis we found a
lot of evidence for Fusion transcripts
uh bridging between um viral insertions
and then host genome flanking nearby in
many or most of our cancer samples and
you can see a predominant Gene that was
hit in each of these many of them appear
to be uh well-known contributors to
cancer such as tp63 which I'll tell a
little bit more about in a few
moments so um this was an example in the
cell line
sec9 on chromosome 9 where we found
amplification and rearrangements around
a transcription Factor called foxy1 our
RNA SE data indicated that foxy one's
expression R was massively upregulated
in the same cell line in comparison to
all the other cells which don't have hbv
integration at the same site and what
you can see from a heat map analysis is
that foxy1 and its neighbor on
chromosome 9 are dramatically
upregulated specifically in the cell
line that has this looping event of HPV
in the
neighborhood another example of a
genetic impact of the virus is shown
here where in uh the cell line called
SEC 47 we saw insertional break points
uh at a gene called
tp63 part of the very well-known uh p-53
family where the virus had inserted
right into the Gene and you can see
again massive upregulation of um or copy
number change I should say of the genome
and then what we found by looking at the
RNA SE data and using race analysis is a
large number of um uh orphan transcripts
that were Fusion transcripts expressed
from the virus Downstream of the uh
viral insertional site so that uh we saw
a range of splice variants that were
three prime end um truncated transcripts
of p63 as shown here and when we looked
on Northern analysis we saw a the
predominant band on Northern was
shortened in the cell line SEC 47 in
comparison to control samples shown here
and Western blotting showed that carboxy
terminol truncated protein was expressed
from this truncated transcript so this
is an example of HPV breaking a gene and
really disrupting it uh uh in the cancer
cell now more recently we turned to um
study a collection of primary tumors uh
to understand whether or not the same
kind of events can be happening broadly
across human cancers that are ass
associated with HPV and I should say
that um HPV is associated with about 5%
of all human cancers and in certain
anatomical sites that uh rate is
increasing and that includes head and
neck cancers so when we did whole genome
sequencing in a panel of um human
cancers we found again as I said before
a range of uh insertional breakpoints
connecting the viral genome at the top
to the host genome at the bottom across
a range of uh sites in the different
samples as well uh we recently have
conducted um long range sequencing using
a novel uh platform that alumina
provides and this confirms some of these
complex structural variants that we've
identified in our samples so this is one
of the primary tumors that we've been
studying and again at the top you can
see really strong evidence for a looping
event I've shown you this several times
so this should look familiar uh but what
you can see is amplification of the host
genome it ranges up to maybe tfold
amplification of the host genome and
then as well um uh we see evidence for
break points that connect the different
parts of this U rearranged structure and
these were confirmed using this long
range uh platform from aluminum so the
way that this works is alumin receives
whole whole genome DNA and they fragment
the DNA to approximately 10 kilobase
fragments and then they fragment those
10 KB chunks and barcode them uh
sequence them all and then recombine
them into 10 KB contigs which are these
long reads shown at the bottom which I'm
circling now and what you can see is
that these long reads Faithfully
confirmed our structures our models of
how HPV inserted into the host genome
and Bridge these discontinuous parts of
the uh of the uh U genome and so each of
these colored lines here purple and
orange and red and so on indicates a
different long read that uh captured um
different parts of these um uh
insertional break points that we
identified and so what this indicates is
that uh our model seems to be correct so
far in terms of um these complex genomic
structural variance and the structures
that we're observing and we think that
long read sequencing can certainly help
in the future to resolve additional
complicated structures so one thing that
we observed in this case that I'm
showing in this figure is that um
actually the virus structure itself is
different in different copies of the
insertion so at the top is an intact
piece of the viral genome and at the
bottom is a piece of the viral genome
that lacked an internal approximately 50
or 75 base pair fragment of the virus
that is a little white Gap here at the
bottom of this figure and the long read
sequencing was able to resolve this in a
way that we would not have been able to
see it previously so we're we're hoping
that the long read sequencing will
really shut a lot of additional light on
the structures that we see very commonly
in HPV Associated uh
cancers so just in conclusion uh we're
using a range of molecular molecular
methods including h sequencing as as
well as this long read sequencing as
well as fish and sky and other methods
to characterize HPV insertions in human
cancers we found a spectrum of different
mutations in the cancers as was expected
and we saw frequently a loss of E2 of
the virus uh we see widespread
integration sites without really
evidence for hotspots of viral insertion
we do see local clustering of these
events in cancers so that in one given
tumor we see uh again and again the
virus is present in the neighborhood
where it has landed in different
structures uh uh but across different
tumors we don't see the same sites being
used exactly again and again we see
evidence with r seek of ARL host Fusion
transcripts and we we very consistently
observe uh expression of the viral
anagen E6 and E7 so uh we identified in
summary we identified that uh very
commonly in human cancers HPV is
associated with focal genomic
instability uh and we proposed a looping
model as the basis for this instability
and as I said before if you want to read
more about it please turn to our uh
recent paper in genome research we found
that the virus uh disrupts um post genes
by a variety of mechanisms they can
include amplifications deletions
chromosomal trans lications antisense
transcripts team breaking and then as I
said at the just at the end here we're
using currently long read sequencing to
resolve and confirm some of these
complex structural variants that are
associated with HPV insertions so I'm
just going to end with my
acknowledgement slide again I really
appreciate the contributions of our
fabulous team that we have listed here
um I'm going to hopefully turn on the
question and answer section here so if
you have questions please enter them in
and I will see if I can address any of
them I see there are no questions at the
moment so I'm just going to wait for a
moment and um see if uh if you have any
questions I would like in the meantime
also to thank fio conference live for uh
hosting us this is a I think an
interesting and great new way to uh
present data and uh so if any of you
have any questions please and the
in I'm going to wait a couple moments
here okay so there is a question uh
comes from NIH and the question is uh
does this contribute to chromis and it's
a great question um we think that um
it's distinct we think that this looping
process may be distinct from mechanisms
of chromis for a variety of reasons and
um the main one is is that uh these
events appear to have some level of
organization to them so um they are
um uh recurrent and we see concatamers
of the host genome that are arrayed head
to tail head detail and inverted and so
on that are really organized by contrast
my understanding of chromis is that uh
it really is kind of a random shattering
locally of the chromosome so that chunks
of hosal fragments are stitched together
in a connectivity pattern that's that's
we can't discern a pattern it's it's
random and so that's that's one big
difference I think between them but it's
an interesting question maybe the
phenomenon of chromis has some
relationship to origin of replication or
something that's U that we don't know
about at the moment so a very
interesting uh question so there's
another question and that is
um are the HPV subtypes that are not
high-risk or cancerous unable to uh
cause genomic amplifications and
rearrangements and that's an interesting
question and I I have to say I don't
know the answer to that I have a sense
that um the lowrisk uh types are likely
not integrated uh but I I believe that
they're maintained
episomally uh and they don't cause
cancer and so their persistence is uh is
unlikely and I I'm not sure that that's
been very well studied but uh that's
that is an interesting question and I
can certainly follow up further
offline uh with you if you want to email
me and we can uh um discuss further so
there's another question again from NIH
and it's uh can you see this in cancers
other than those traditionally
associated with human Poma virus and the
answer is uh there is there are
interesting similarities with other
viral uh insertional events that happen
in other types of cancer that are not
HPV related and a famous example is
Hepatitis B virus uh insertions that
occur in liver Cancers and they seem to
be there are many similarities really
between the focal genomic instability
that we see with HPV and what others
have seen recently with
hbb so I don't see see any more
questions I'm going to wait just a more
moment or two and then we're going to
sign off so
um thank you all so much for attending I
really appreciate it and uh if you have
any further questions just send an email
we're happy to follow up thank
you